raise your hand if you are
data literate i know i can't see you but
i'm going to imagine that all of you
raised your hands
let's talk data expert to data expert
about our own data literacy
hello my name is laura ludwig and
together we're going to take a fresh
look in the mirror to
uncover some places where we can grow
our skills
before we do let's get on the same page
about what data literacy even means
think for a moment about how you define
that term
have one in mind good the official
definition that we're going to work from
is the ability to read understand create
and communicate data as information
data is information that's a great
definition
we're going to expand upon it
let's get out of our data bubble for a
minute i'd like you to think about a
child in primary school
perhaps it's your own child or a niece
or nephew maybe it's you
as a child now think about their primary
language
can that child read a storybook can they
write a short story
now based on the verbs from our
definition
that child can read can understand can
create
and can communicate using words so we're
done
right that child is literate i think
most of us would agree that there's
still a lot for that child to learn
before they can read the greats like
coulson whitehead virginia woolf or even
j.k rowling
and that's just to get them to read and
understand those authors not to mention
writing like one
so it might be considered reasonable to
visualize that child's literacy
as a continuum a child goes from
learning the actual abcs in primary
school
to experiencing a variety of literature
through secondary school
at this point the child now young adult
might decide to major in literature
at university and start doing some
research
if they end up crafting an award-winning
book
we might consider this the pinnacle of
literacy as they've mastered
all of the components of their craft
this seems like a valid mental model
let's see if it applies to data literacy
the equivalent of the abcs for data
literacy would be something as
simple as using graphs this level of
data literacy would apply to
many people at our organizations sales
marketing finance operations
within those groups we might also have
some people who are particularly savvy
with data
these are the people who might be able
to configure a dashboard in a
self-service tool
if they're given a good data source
beyond that we have people who work with
data
all the time so these are people who are
writing advanced queries and building
data products for others
and all the way up to tuning machine
learning
models and algorithms the problem i have
with this model is that it
only accounts for technical expertise
in our definition that would equate to
being able to read and create
but what about understand and
communicate
those aren't tied to technical skills
let's add a second dimension to our
model to try to solve this
now our previous spectrum is called data
competency
which roughly equates to technical
skills of working with data the reading
and creating component of our definition
the second dimension is called insight
translation
this is the process of understanding the
data and putting it to use in some way
this axis relies heavily on
understanding and communicating
components of our definition
let's switch to thinking about the
typical user who might
operate at these different technical
levels
as we consider what insight translation
is
it seems reasonable to assume that the
people who are closest to the business
actions
need the highest level of insight
translation capability
as a sales manager they might need to
translate a graph
about sales this quarter into tactical
actions to reach their quota
the sales power user might provide more
data
and a more nuanced answer to questions
around which regions need additional
support
this quarter a data analyst might be
asked to evaluate whether those regions
all have similar characteristics that
explain the lower performance
and a data scientist might be asked to
predict which regions are going to need
more support
next quarter based on what we know about
historical performance
these insights from the more technical
roles
have to go up the chain to the manager
in order to actually be acted upon and
engage with the regional sales team to
help
make those sales quotas there are
different amounts of insight translation
that different roles can and should do
we shouldn't all be at the same level
companies want to be data driven we
don't have to look far
to see an article about that
many companies focus on building the
technical skills and
while that's important having the people
who can do the more technical things is
important
it's the insight translation that
makes the magic happen i would currently
place many of us
in our various roles as ranking pretty
low
on the insight translation piece i think
we've got a lot that we can learn here
and we can do that for ourselves as data
experts
we can help our business counterparts do
the same
that's what we're going to focus on for
the rest of our time together building
insight translation skills
for us as data experts
so remember that child from a few
minutes ago
that when we tried to check off the
boxes it did not help us in concluding
that the child was literate
well how should we be evaluating for
literacy
if we can't rely on a list well
we're going to do it by looking at key
behaviors and attitudes
an easy way to think about key behaviors
is to frame it in this way
as a data literate person you and then
fill in the blank we're going to look at
eight of these in detail
as we go through i want you to assess
yourself
go ahead and grab a piece of paper and a
pen and draw a copy of this octagon for
yourself
as i describe each behavior reflect on
your own skill level
and give yourself a score one to ten
a one is i've never heard of this before
and a ten
is i do this consistently without
thinking about it
then think about where you need to be as
part of your own role
write that down and draw a little arrow
something like this
and keep track for yourself you ready
let's go ahead and dive in as a data
literate person
you work independently with data
being independent with something means
you're comfortable working with it on
your own
you don't need someone prescribing
exactly what an output should look like
or
what steps to take to reach a conclusion
you can clean your data and formulate
your data to
fit your output product appropriately
without needing to rely on others to do
that work
that's not to say you're a lone wolf
having the ability to do it is not the
same as always doing it
you may work in a team and have a
specific set of things that you are
responsible for in a given project
but you also have to know the rest of
the data life cycle
so that you can speak accurately about
the tasks that surround your own
as a data literate person you
collaborate to define problems
when working with a new analysis
question you discern
what type of output is going to move the
needle to answer that question
to do that you have to know a little
about it about the data that's available
you have to ask relevant questions about
the analysis use case
and then suggest ideas for what output
could be
this is going to be different depending
on how well defined the question is that
you're presented with
sometimes problems are broadly defined
when they come across your desk and
you've got to whittle them down
into a concrete question that can be
answered with data
other times questions are far too
focused and they miss a bigger picture
so you have to find the right way to
open up
the scope of the problem so that you can
situate a laser-focused question into a
bigger picture
as a data literate person you constantly
learn new things
this includes learning about new data
domains new tools new methods new
algorithms just to name a few
for us as data experts the one that
might be harder
for us is learning new data domains
particularly learning the context
of that domain for example if you've
never worked with clickstream data
there's a lot to learn from a technical
perspective about
how it's structured and what it logs but
there's also a significant amount of
context
to learn what business process created
this
why did it get created and what kinds of
things
can we actually do with it building
skills and techniques to get up to speed
on a new data space
quickly is imperative for a highly data
literate person
you can do this in a number of ways i
like to find
videos from industry leaders or read
books or blogs on a particular topic
one of my favorite ones is finding a
similar data set on kaggle or data.world
that has concrete prompts and a data
dictionary
to help me translate between what i'm
learning about the context
and what i know from a technical
perspective
not only do we need to know how to learn
something new
but we also need to engage with new
learning materials
with a purpose by relating everything
back
to the problem at hand that we're trying
to solve
we can craft insightful questions to
learn more from our colleagues who are
requesting our help
by getting enough knowledge ahead of
time it makes meetings with key
stakeholders
all the more productive because they're
not spending time
teaching you the basics of their
business instead the focus can be on the
specific implementation
of the basics within your organization
as a data literate person you use
technology strategically
part of learning any new tool well is
learning when to apply it
we use the simplest form available to
manage the complexity that's necessary
based on our data
or at least we should this means that we
don't build an animated chart when a
static image will do
this means that we don't build five
versions of a report when a filter
could solve the problem by keeping an
eye on the final solution from the
beginning
we make sure that we have the right
scope of technical investment at
every step in the process i find
for me that this comes up a lot during
the exploratory analysis phase of many
projects
because i come from a data visualization
background
i end up wasting a lot of time trying to
make my eda visualizations into
presentation worthy plots
strategic technologies also relates to
knowing
when to stop an analysis we know
that we need to avoid overfitting our
algorithms that we need to be strategic
about
when we use our heavy computing
resources we also need to be
considerate of the precision that's
required to act on the question
that we're working to answer do we need
a
directionally correct answer or is
precision required to the hundredths
place of our metric in order to make a
decision
we should aim for the minimum
specificity that's required
for making the decision and nothing more
as a data literate person you adapt your
communication styles
you base your communication on the needs
of the audience
to do that you have to know your
audience and what they're going to do
with the data product you're creating
for them
you also have to know how they're going
to engage
do they only want to know when things
are going wrong in their business
or do they want to have a regular
reminder that things are just fine
are they the type that's going to go out
and refresh a report or do they need an
email popping into their inbox with the
highlights
of course some of those specifics get
accounted for during the solution design
process but being able to anticipate
and delight our audience with something
that they need in a format that they
want
is a way to really shine as a data
expert
as a data literate person you exercise
empathy for
other perspectives while you're getting
to know your audience and what they need
you're exercising empathy you're
considering
their perspective to create something
that answers the most pressing questions
even if they haven't articulated those
questions yet yet
by stepping into their shoes you can
start to anticipate what the next
questions will be
once they see the answers to the
questions they've already asked
one of the perspectives that we should
always apply throughout an analysis is
that of the skeptic
we need to recognize that data is not
always as objective
as we want it to be there are hidden
biases and data stemming from
how it's collected analyzed and
presented
research questions can have hidden bias
as well we should approach
every new data set every new question
with a degree of skepticism
our aim is to understand why
the question is being asked and if there
are other questions that aren't being
asked that maybe should be
bias isn't inherently malicious and by
interrogating our data and our analyses
we can help ensure that we're
contributing to a more equitable
and truthful understanding of the world
so
how do we know what questions aren't
being asked
how do we learn to see through other
perspectives
it's all about breadth here we've got to
read widely we must consume a variety of
news and entertainment sources
we must practice getting into other
people's heads when i say read widely
i don't just mean non-fiction or
business books
i mean fiction if the last fiction book
you read was in school
of some kind that is your main homework
coming away from this talk is to find a
fiction book
and commit to reading it before the end
of the year
in addition to expanding our perspective
by consumption
we need to be expanding our networks to
include many different voices
this can be anyone that doesn't look or
think like you
pi data is a great way to do exactly
that so you've already made a good
choice for your own data literacy
by being here today to hear from
perspectives around the world
as a data literate person you comprehend
and critique
your work and your data you approach
problems with an
open and engaged mind coupled with a
discerning attitude
showing up in this way makes sure that
you're willing to kill your darlings
this is a familiar bit of advice given
to writers but it also applies here
it means we have to be willing to throw
away something that we've worked on
if it's getting in the way of the
overall analysis
this might mean that we exclude an
interesting but confusing visualization
of our data for the sake of clarity
it might mean that we can't do the
segmented analysis we planned because
we don't have enough data to get the
statistical power that we need
it can mean walking away from a
particular algorithm because
the tuning parameters dictate that you
would need more computing power than you
have budget for
all of these are examples of killing our
darlings in the data world
and finally as a data literate person
you translate
evidence more than just valuing evidence
you can communicate
the strength of your analysis you know
what information
is relevant to which people and you
articulate
your reasoning clearly and concisely
knowing what's relevant to people is
another part of knowing your audience
you've got to know what evidence they
value
accurately describing the strength of
our evidence is one of the most useful
things we can do when presenting an
analysis
doing this well means outlining
weaknesses clearly
knowing how to talk about statistical
power
and error terms with non-data experts is
critical
and it takes practice often business
users are not going to be interested
in the statistics lesson even if you're
exceptionally good at explaining
those things they're only going to care
about
what conclusions can we be confident
about learning how to articulate your
evidence in terms of business risk and
reward
will help you share evidence in concrete
ways without
becoming known as the statistics
professor
to recap here we have eight key
behaviors that we should be aiming for
there are a lot of things to cover here
take a look at your score sheet
for any segment where you're at least
two points away from where you think you
should be
shade that in real quick i hope you have
at least one
if not many because next we're going to
walk through some methods for building
and
exercising these behaviors i want you to
keep your octagon handy
each exercise targets multiple behaviors
and you can quickly reference your needs
to figure out which ones are going to
give you the most bang for your buck
a word of warning many of these
behaviors that we've been looking at
have
nothing to do with our technical skills
which means that some of these are going
to fall out of your comfort zone
it may even feel unproductive in the
moment that you're doing them
but in trying something new you're
already practicing one of the key
behaviors which is
constantly learning new things
let's start with flexibility and
communications
you'll want to pay particular attention
here if you have any of the bottom three
segments filled in
which are adapting new things or
learning new things
using technology strategically and
adapting communications
think about how you typically share
information
maybe you're on twitter regularly or if
you're an academic you may share your
work
in journals those two examples of
communication
are on opposite ends of the spectrum in
terms of length
but they require just as much care and
crafting
why well twitter requires conciseness
you've got to distill your thoughts into
280 characters or
chunks of 280 characters if you're gonna
do a thread
on the other end when writing something
longer
you have to craft a strong argument with
a thoughtful structure and clear logic
providing evidence that supports your
claims this requires a lot of attention
to detail
when things get really interesting is
when you start
flexing your muscles to take one type of
message
and put it into another form like taking
a tweet
and making it into a paper or taking a
paper and turning it into a tweet
and all of the different levels in
between which include emails and blog
posts and
all sorts of other articles i like to
call this communications yoga
take a small fact build a story or take
a story and
turn it into a few sentences
there are a lot of ways to do this
the first and most important part is to
intentionally get away from your usual
communications tool
do you always build powerpoint slides to
share your findings
instead try building a storyline with a
tool like
flourish or tableau you could also try
adopting the amazon model which is to
write out a briefing
memo for everyone to read in the first
few minutes of meeting
and let your words and documentation
present your argument
and what you found even if you don't end
up using this new material for a meeting
the process of getting out of your usual
methods is valuable
and you should try running meetings a
little bit differently nobody likes the
same boring structure all the time
one of my favorite ways of getting clear
on my messages is what i call the
post-it note distillation
check your octagon if you've got
adapting communication
critiquing data and work working
independently with data or collaborating
to define a problem
you should try this with your next
analysis
the objective of this activity is to
summarize the main
questions and key insights of an
analysis
onto a post-it note by restricting the
real estate
of your communication to a inch square
piece of paper
you're forced to write down only the
most important things
i like to do this with my visualizations
too if i can't draw a skeleton graph
of my key analysis outputs i'm not just
done distilling
my key information this often leads to
asking more probing questions about the
desired outcome
it's often really helpful to do this at
the beginning phases of a project
because it helps everyone get on the
same page about what is most important
both on the team and with customers
an advanced version of the post-it note
exercise is to rely
entirely on words specifically
the 1 000 most common words of your
language
this idea was inspired by a book called
thing explainer by randall the grill
if you're not familiar he draws the
webcomics
xkcd and has written a number of books
in thing explainer he uses only the 1000
most common english words to explain
how things like nuclear reactors and
rockets work
he uses simple words in greater number
to describe
things for example nuclear becomes
hard to find heavy metal but his intent
is still
clear and understandable to anyone even
if they don't know the technical
vocabulary
in the data space we might have an
analysis that required us to impute some
of our data
instead of talking about imputation
methods we might say something like
how we filled in the empty spaces with
good guesses
this clarity of idea is what we're
aiming to develop
once we can do that we can add technical
terms back in
if it is going to help us be more
concise but only if it makes sense for
our audience
on the other end of the communication
spectrum we have what i like to call
the tough q a take a peek at your
octagon
if you are looking to build empathy for
other perspectives
critique your working data and translate
evidence
this activity is for you with this
exercise we want to build
flexibility and confidence with
communicating our insights
here's how we do this first build a list
of questions that you may get about a
data product
you might already have a good list of
questions based on things you've been
asked previously
this list should include things about
the data
source the quality the frequency and
the methodology the cleaning the
analysis methods the sources of error
next put on your investigative
journalist hat and get
really skeptical elaborate your
questions
the more difficult or obscure the
questions are the better
try to twist your own work around
considering how someone
with a different background might
misinterpret your choices
once you have your list your next task
is to hunt down
and document the answers to these
questions this process is going to do
two things
one it's going to highlight the places
in your analysis
where you need to apply more rigor or
remove some bias
and two it prepares you to go into
deeper detail at a moment's notice
pairing this exercise with a
distillation exercise
helps give you a ton of flexibility in
talking about the output of your
analysis
the final skill building activity i want
to talk about is something i'm calling
practice class if you've got
independence with data
collaboration on defining problems
learning new things or exercising
empathy shaded in you'll want to host
yourself one of these
this concept stems from masterclass
where a person
shares their expertise with others who
want to learn about a concept
in this version the goal is to practice
being a beginner at something
it can often be hard to remember what it
was like to be a beginner
and it can sometimes feel intimidating
to willingly be new to something and ask
the most basic questions
so how do we do this start by forming a
small group of colleagues with a wide
array of interests
it shouldn't be particularly formal
something like a lunch gathering once a
week would be a great place to start
each person picks something that they
are an expert in an ideal topic
is something you can explain without
much preparation
is interesting to learn about and most
importantly is non-work related
examples include things like how to make
the best guacamole
or starting a bullet journal or how to
find the best travel deals
each week one person talks for 15
minutes about their selected topic
the remaining time is used for people to
ask questions of the presenter
and exercise their curiosity the goal is
to fill at least 15 more minutes with
discussion
based on questions that students ask
there are only two rules
for a practice class first the presenter
can't use
slides this rule prevents over preparing
and keeps the gatherings casual
props or a visual aid that's printed out
can be used but
try to keep everything as simple as
possible
the second rule is that students are not
allowed to use google or
any other search engine to look anything
up instead
all questions must go to the presenter
this reinforces the acceptability of
being
a novice as well as helps the entire
group be curious together
one of my favorite quotes comes from
helen mcinnis nothing is interesting
unless you're interested
by engaging with the expert in your
group on whatever they presented
you help everyone be more curious
we've covered eight key behaviors and
four skill building exercises
you've got a self-made plan on where you
need to grow your capabilities
i now have two challenges for you the
first one is this
in 2021 commit to advancing your skill
level
from where it is now to your personal
target
and at least two of these behaviors why
two
i think you're going to find it's more
challenging to move just one
so may as well go big
a second challenge you may have already
seen this one coming
because i alluded to it earlier read a
new book before the end of 2020.
i have a few recommendations for you if
you need some inspiration
some of these are fiction some are
non-fiction don't worry about
reading all these small covers you can
check out that link where i've got
two lists on goodreads that you can use
to find
a good recommendation for what you want
to read at the end of this year
finally i want this to mark the
beginning of a conversation
i want to connect with you i'd love to
hear how you're building your insight
translation skills and your data
competency skills too
i am after all a data expert like you i
love hearing about cool projects and how
data is making the world better
you can find me on social media at the
links listed here or
drop me an email let me know what you
want to hear more about and how i can
help you
thank you